okay let's uh get started i'm mike
douglas and this is the new technologies
and mathematics seminar of the
cmsa at harvard university it's the
first talk of our semester and we're
delighted to have alex davies of uh
deepmind who will talk about their
recent work on
advancing mathematics like combining
human intuition with uh machine learning
uh recent paper and nature and several
other papers with the uh deep blood
results uh alex got uh phd at that
cambridge and as he says he's been doing
uh fun things at the d the mind ever
since let me uh offer as i always do to
uh you you can ask questions there'll be
time for questions at the end but uh you
can also put questions on
a little professional math quiz
you know you can also put questions on
chat and uh
i will look at them and not raise them
at an appropriate moment
so with no further ado uh alex take it
away
great uh thanks so much mike for having
me here
for the introduction and yes i really
encourage people just ask questions as
we're going along um i'll make sure i
break pretty frequently to do so um and
they'll definitely be the most effective
way of
going through this together
so uh yeah today i'm just going to talk
to you about this work that we've done
recently working together with
mathematicians to see how we can use
machine learning to help them
uh in the work that they do
so to give you a kind of a brief deep
mind
company mission slide denies aim to
solve intelligence to advance science
and benefit humanity
and obviously in this work what we're
looking at in particular is whether we
can advance pure mathematics there's a
lot of really exciting work happening
with machine at the intersection of
machine learning and mathematics at the
moment
but particularly we were driven by the
goal to see whether or not we could help
make advances in pure mathematics
and current research mathematics with
the current tools that we have in
machine learning
and so overall you can kind of see this
talk as a bit of a pitch for
the potential of these tools in
interdisciplinary research and the fact
that they really can help mathematicians
get to new and interesting results and
that there's
i think more value still there to be had
so we published this in nature at the
end of last year
and importantly for us the reviews from
the mathematical reviewers in the
community in general have been
reasonably positive so far both in terms
of
uh the appeal of the approach and the
impact of the mathematical results that
we were able to find independently of
the use of machine learning in order to
find them
a big part of this was the
mathematicians that we worked with so
for this work our collaborators mark
black and andres duhash from oxford
uh who are collaborators in not theory
which is a subfield of topology and then
jordy williamson
who's an amazing professor in the
university of sydney who works in
representation theory
broadly subfield of algebra
and these are
the papers that we published
independently
of the nature paper with them that we've
submitted to mathematical journals now
and i'll go a little bit into details on
the individual results
as we go through the talk
so our original motivation for
doing this work
came from the idea of ramanujanism
mathematician
and ramanujan in particular being famous
for
being a particularly intuitive
mathematician who would be able to see
patterns in numbers that other people
couldn't
and often talking about this in a very
intuitive way about them coming to in
dreams or
or similar kind of things
and uh
then either himself proving these
theorems uh these conjectures into
theorems or having them
be proved by other people
and this highlighted
the importance of a part of the
mathematical process that i didn't
appreciate
as much going into this work not being a
mathematician myself
but it's this important part
of mathematics of finding conjectures
that are useful and interesting
in some meaningful way in this case
by looking at data and examples of them
so obviously this is not a particularly
new
framing of how mathematics is done i
would say this is not how all
mathematics proceeds but a good amount
can be seen through this lens of
experimental mathematics
where
mathematicians
look at examples of the objects they're
studying
detect patterns and then formulate a
conjecture from them
so in the case
uh if we go back before computers the
prime number theorem
comes from
hands
in a painstaking fashion large tables of
prime numbers
to then look at these examples
detect patterns and formulate them as
conjectures and ultimately prove them
the most famous
probably computational example of
finding a conjecture would be the virgin
spinosa diet conjecture which is one of
the millennium prizes
and that was found in the 60s
with early use of computers in cambridge
to kind of generate these properties of
elliptic curves
that
you know the virgin swedish and diet
could look at and posit this fairly
simple relationship with
so what we have tried to do here is take
a kind of reasonable next step
to
both compute the examples and then
computationally detect the patterns
and this is particularly interesting
now
because of the scale of objects that
we're able to compute we can obviously
compute
many examples of many types of
mathematical objects now
that we couldn't before
and we're in the regime where it can be
interesting to computationally detect
these patterns
either because the
spaces are very
and difficult to visualize to find
patterns all the objects themselves are
structured
or very large in a way where they're
also difficult for mathematicians to
manually analyze
so this is a kind of
very
cartoon flowchart of
how we found a way to work together with
mathematicians
and one of the things we wanted to try
and get across was one model for
how mathematicians could think about
the tools that we have in machine
learning
in a way which is helpful for them and
so
this was one of the framings that we
came up with essentially it was around
really reinforcing this idea
that
one of the things that we can do in
machine learning is
find functions so there needs to be a
hypothesis of the form that there exists
a function
and then explaining how
in order to use machine learning to find
a function we need to generate a dot
generate data from
uh chosen from a particular distribution
that we can then train a supervised
model
to see if there is a relationship if
such a function
may exist and if
uh we can predict
in this case y of z from x of z
above chance
appropriately defined this implies that
there might be some kind of pattern
there which is interesting
and then using techniques saliency
techniques and techniques uh for model
attribution to try and
elicit information which is useful for
mathematicians then conjecture a
candidate for what this closed form
candidate for this function could be
and repeating this process a number of
times either reformulating hypotheses or
altering the sampling distribution
um
not necessarily to improve the
performance of the supervised model but
just
to get at information which is useful
for the mathematician
with hopefully the ultimate goal of
proving theorem
so
hopefully that will become a little bit
more clear as i give some examples of
this
again if there's any early questions
please do feel free to jump in
um this is just a short illustration
to try and
make concrete what would happen in a
very simple example case uh so this is
this is a toy case where you might say
we want to rediscover the euler's rule
this um
case of the relationship between
vertices edges and faces
and it would be very easy for us to find
this
one way of many many ways you can find
this
is you can generate a number of these
shapes
calculate a number of properties or
features or statistics of them and
it would be very easy with the machine
learning model
even in this case as we can see since we
know the formula
linear regression would be able to
identify that for example you could
predict the faces given the value of the
vertices and the edges
once we
knew that it was possible to compute it
would be very easy in this case to plot
it to see what the actual
closed form is
and we could test on arbitrarily more
complicated examples and it would always
be true
yeah
so
this is another
version of that cycle
which
hopefully should seem
relatively familiar as a kind of just
general experimentation cycle or a
cycle of conjecturing in conjunction
with um machine learning and i think
what we were just trying to convey go
through the examples in the framework
is just exactly how this fits in
for both people in machine learning and
mathematicians because sometimes
certainly in our experience when we
started it was not clear what the best
way in which to do this
was uh as we said we've had some
reasonable results in terms of getting
to
uh proofs and conjectures
and so i think the most useful thing i
can do is go through these examples
uh and describe them in a little bit
more detail
um there any questions at this stage
cool
so in which case we'll go first into the
example of not theory
um
i'll
give some kind of high level
introduction to the mathematical areas
so
again open to questions but i apologize
if this is too trivial for some people
or
not sufficiently deep
so not theory is the study of
closed loops embedded in three
dimensions
as you can see in illustration
of one here one of the simplest knots
and as this is a subfield of topology
what we care about for one of these
objects is we consider that any two
knots are the same if it's possible to
smoothly deform
uh one into the other without passing it
through itself
and
so it's very reasonable to think
heuristically of these as the kind of
normal knots we have in everyday life
except
instead of being an unconnected piece of
string
you would always just have to close the
loop at the end
so this is a pretty popular object of
studying low dimensional topology and
it's been studied for
100 years
a bit more
and one of the the ways that these are
studied
is by identifying and studying
invariants so um essentially just
properties
of a knot
and there's a lot of many many different
invariants of the other not that you can
calculate
but there are a number of different
classes of invariants that come from
different subfields of mathematics
and in particular
there's two classes that we'll talk
about which are
the geometry of the knot or geometric
invariants
and the algebraic structure of knots
and roughly
you can think of this
as being that the geometry there's a
kind of well-defined way to talk about
the geometry
of a knot
and then you can take measurements of
that geometry so you can take that it's
meaningful to talk about the volume of a
knot
or different measurements of parts of it
and there's also this kind of separate
algebraic structure of knots where you
take a diagram of the knot
and you either define a graph or
recurrence relations on it which allow
you to calculate a quantity which is the
same for any
diagram of that knot
however these are fairly separate
and one of the outstanding questions in
that theory is if there are any direct
connections between these invariants
and up until now
there's one particularly famous
conjecture called the volume conjecture
which says that the volume is encoded
by one of the polynomial invariants
but it's
not proven
and it's one of the very few
conjectures that we have
so what we essentially have
is that we know that these are related
because they're both
uh properties of the underlying object
they're not uh but we're not uh it
wasn't known if there was really that
much in the way of connections directly
between the two of them
and what this looks like in terms of the
data set
is uh on the left you can see
illustrations of a knot and then
measurements of its geometric invariance
which tends to be real or complex
and then measurements of its algebraic
invariants which tend to be integers or
polynomials with integer coefficients
and so as we're kind of getting to a
machine learning formulation we're just
asking the question can you predict the
algebraic invariance from the geometric
invariants
so we're going to do the simplest thing
is train um a feedforward neural network
to predict the signature from the
geometric invariants and i'll talk about
neural networks because it's what we use
largely but that's really not necessary
and we don't specify that in the paper i
think any supervised learning method
would give you the same results here
and so the very surprising result from
the perspective of mark and andras
where that you can predict a number of
the algebraic variants and in particular
signature very well just by looking at
the geometric structure
so they had assumed that there would be
no
useful information in the geometry about
what the signature is based on their
existing intuition
and you can see here plotted the
predicted signature from the model on
the x-axis versus the true signature on
the y
and a perfect
predictor a perfect function would be
exactly along that dotted diagonal
and so you can see it's not perfect but
it's pretty good it's in fact very good
relative to what they would have
expected
questions about this yeah yeah go for it
okay so one is is how has it decided
would this particular did you try uh
many quantities this is one that worked
or whether as you said there was not an
intuition that this was possible
yes i'm i i think i missed a bigger
question was it why the signature in
particular
well i mean why how did you decide how
did the research team decide which ones
to try to predict did you try to break
every invariant
um yeah yeah exactly so um in terms of
the two classes uh the classes were the
kind of obvious choice so when he said
like
the way we posed the question originally
to my address was uh where
where would it be very interesting if
there was a connection where you're not
like you don't necessarily believe or
you have no reason to expect there would
be one
and their first answer was well if there
was one between the geometric and
algebraic and variance that would be
huge
it's probably not one but that seems
like a reasonable place to start
and then once we collected
these invariants on both sides
uh we did just to try to predict each of
the algebraic invariants from
all of the geometric invariants
and um and so there are a number more of
the algebraic invariants and we could do
a reasonable job
on quite a number of them
and also like especially for small knots
where we started
uh a bunch of the algebraic areas are
quite correlated too
and so then the reason that we went with
the signature is it was
uh for a number of reasons and i think
this comes up a bunch is that um these
choices were made
with a lot of information coming from
the mathematicians of what they would
prefer to pursue and what seemed
interesting and provable and what was
good about the signature
is that it's one of the simplest
algebraic invariants
um so it's possibly easier for reason
about improve
uh it's cheaper to calculate so we can
calculate it for large knots and do more
tests
and it was one of the the better
predicted ones
so i think those are kind of three
reasons but also
just
probably fundamentally the answer is
they found that the most interesting so
that's the one that we focused on
so furthermore
but let me uh ask another question was
that in principle you could have
regarded this as a problem unsupervised
learning to just find any pattern
between the demanding and the variance
would you consider that approach
sorry i really had trouble hearing you
um could you repeat that please maybe my
mask
so
yeah i mean if i were to just start up
an issue i might also say
you know each knot defines a point in a
high dimensional date you know space
through
convergence or invariance and i'm just
looking for any patterns and that's the
problem of unsupervised learning
yeah that's definitely true
i i think that's also a very reasonable
framing i think one of the
the one of the advantages of of the way
that we did it here is that
we've set it up in a way that a priori
we know that if we find a pattern it's
interesting
and um
i think that
we didn't try the unsupervised
approach or this kind of wall-to-wall
uh relationship finding
because the um
i mean we i guess we certainly could
have here but my expectation would be
that
that way you would find a lot of
patterns that the mathematicians either
knew existed or found uninteresting and
there would be more of a filtering step
um that you would need to go through in
order to find things that were
interesting i think um
like a generalization of this and maybe
this is maybe this actually is a better
way to go um you can imagine getting all
of the invariants like you said
and um
and doing
something along those lines right where
you try and predict every invariant from
every other invariant um
but i guess the
information that you would lose there
is that
you would expect
that every invariant is probably quite
predictable given all other invariants
so for example if we had the signature
it's like expected and likely that you'd
be able to predict that quite well from
the other algebraic variants that are
quite correlated
um and so
this is i s this effectively this is
just a way to get some of the mathematic
mathematicians intuition
into the problem and do a filtering step
first rather than starting straight from
the search
um before filtering it down with
mathematicians intuition about what's
interesting or helpful but there's no
fundamental reason why you couldn't
ultimately aim to start where you're
saying start without any
mathematician's intuition whatsoever
okay
alex uh if i could ask another quick
question uh to follow up with that
did you try um
predicting instead of just getting the
signature maybe uh trying to predict the
coefficients of the jones polynomials
did you
try that
that's my first question
and the second question is maybe you'll
talk about this later uh i'd like to i
mean i would be interested in seeing
what exactly what architecture
of mlp that you use
and maybe whether you tried um any
corner methods uh using this geometric
invariance trying to first embed the
geometric invariance to some higher
higher space
and then
try to predict signature
okay yeah great two great questions so i
think the first one
uh
yes we did um
do some prediction tasks on the jones
polynomial coefficients and i think we
could this is now a very long time ago i
think we could do a somewhat okay job um
but i think i should actually this
spurs me to add another point as to why
we chose the signature
is it's also just a really easy machine
learning task because obviously with the
jones polynomial
you do need to split it out into the
different coefficients and the length of
the polynomial changes whereas with the
signature it's just an integer which is
which is very nice and easy
so we didn't explore too much further
down into the jones polynomial and
predicting that from the signature
sorry between that from the geometry um
but my impression is probably we could
do a little bit
i mean it would be in that case uh there
would be more interesting questions
about the architecture of how we would
and representation to some degree of how
we would do that
um and then when you talk about the
architecture of this
feedforward dual network
it's uh
like as simple as you could imagine i
think i don't want to give away the
punchline
for the relationship but the
relationship is sufficiently simple to
find that almost any machine learning
method you could find or any
architecture you used would find the
correct answer
um
in some sense you can imagine that i
think if yeah it from memory it would be
like a three-layer network
with width
say 256.
so you can
imagine that what the network is going
to be doing is some representation
learning where it is embedding this
lower dimensional space of geometric
invariance up into 256 or 512 or
whatever it was to do a couple of
processing steps
uh and then make the prediction of the
signature
um but it was not uh certainly there was
no effort really put into
um the network itself
got it thank
you one very fast question i promise
i'll be fast um so first yeah so you use
you guys used in mlp i know some other
places in the literature sort of in the
mathy ml
interface the people have used simpler
techniques that are more interpretable
like decision trees and logistic
regressions and so on and so forth did
you guys try any of these or did you
have success
um so i did one of the other ones i
often use for testing is a random forest
it's i wouldn't say that's necessarily
that much more interpretable but um
it also comes packaged nicely with
um
a sense of feature importances
which um
we which i would certainly be more
likely to use honestly in this tabular
data regime
when we get to the representation
theorem we're starting to look at graphs
um then i think it makes a lot more
sense to be using neural networks
and there's an advantage to having this
unified
i feel when communicating this have this
unified idea that you can pick a neural
network of your type and use this a
unified type of attribution method
um but yeah so i definitely know random
forest finds it i know small mlps find
it
uh
logistic regression with class yeah if
you're classifying the signature of this
regression i think you probably would um
it is non-linear
so
uh you won't you could probably see
something was happening but you wouldn't
find it as well if it was just a linear
model
i reckon
yeah and the decision tree would
probably find it too i would guess
thank you very much
um cool
so yeah
you trying to model on this
you will probably get some
uh
plot out like this so we know that
there's some relationship to be found
and then the next step that we took
was to try and help them understand
how these predictions were being made
and
the way in which we did this was to take
one of the simplest attribution methods
uh for
uh mlps or for this kind of any
differential model which is
to take the
the gradient saliency so the uh we're
just looking at the gradients
of the predictions
with respect to the different input
features
and
as kind of summing those
absolute values of those over the data
set uh either training or test data set
and then that's what's plotted here so
we're looking at the geometric and
variance and it's normalized attribution
score where we we have this feeling that
if a function is sensitive and this is
sensitivity analysis from traditional
statistics
if the function that's learned is very
sensitive to these parameters that
they're somehow relevant for the
prediction
and you can see very clearly here that
there's three quantities which seem to
be
the function is very sensitive to which
is the original translation longitudinal
translation
and this is also
nice from a mathematical perspective
because
those are all measurements of the same
object they're all measurements of the
cusp of the knot
and again this is this is a nice clear
thing to send back to mark and andres
who
uh
now knowing that a relationship exists
and where to look
uh
could say well if we're looking at the
cusp and these measurements and trying
to predict the signature what what could
possibly be going on here
and they came up with this new
derived invariant called the natural
slope
which is linearly related to the
signature
and i think a nice like
looking back
i feel like
we probably could have used machine
learning for this part the formula is
simple enough
uh that i think we probably could have
found that if we tried it turns out
mathematicians are quite good at this so
we didn't need to
but we find this now linear relationship
between
this derived quantity of the slope and
the signature
and the next step was to
generate a lot of data see whether this
holds
and so we we looked over the first
several million knots
as well as a lot of large randomly
sampled knots and this held
very well we kind of
formulated this conjecture in the
following way
which is
again essentially just looking at the
data and
having mark and andres put forward a
conjecture that seemed reasonable
uh and then spent a bunch of time trying
to help them search for counter examples
and eventually we were able to construct
a counter-example a family of
counter-examples of these uh this
conjecture that we made so we know
that's not true
even though it definitely held the small
nuts and an expectation for random knots
but
if we went back to this original
saliency graph we just kind of
ad hoc took the first three of these
quantities and
originally i'd kind of assumed that the
the following ones were maybe just
artifacts
but if we look at the next ones we have
the imaginary part of the short geodesic
and the injectivity radius and it turns
out that those are necessary quantities
in order to control
for this last degree of freedom
so going back and looking at this
mark and andres were able to come up
with the final form of the conjecture
which
then held for everything we could find
and then
the the next step was they were actually
able to prove this
which we gave no contribution to
but was a really important validation
that
we were continuing to find a conjecture
that was not only interesting but also
something that they could ultimately
prove
um so
i kind of take another pause there and
check if anyone has any questions
i have a quick question um when uh um so
when you came up with these counter
examples i don't know if they were like
a family that you could generate them
like
like but if you could like would you be
able to then do the same you know redo
your
calculation with this family of counter
examples and do the saliency and then
figure out where like
uh yeah
this is
an excellent suggestion and we didn't we
didn't do this but actually we 100
should have and my very strong feeling
is that if you um
if we just generated these braids and
then redid the prediction and
we did the saliency i think you would
see
the injectivity radius and the short
geodesics show up very much more
strongly because those are exactly the
examples for which it's necessary and
the effect is relatively small for the
smaller knots so
yeah that is something we missed the
first time i think is
probably exactly what we should have
done
um i have a question as well if i may
yes so maybe you mentioned it but i
didn't catch it so uh was the proof done
by pen and paper or was it also
you use machine learning for the proof
as well or only for the conjecture
uh the machining was only for the
conjecture the proof was all uh pen and
paper or in the in the minds of mark and
andres
i see thank you
of course
do you know how hard the proof was i
mean once they you know once they uh
once they had the conjecture um
yeah you know
yes that's a good question i guess i'm
i'm not a well-qualified person to
answer this i'd say
kind of
kind of hard a good amount of hard hard
enough that
it hard enough that it needed mark so
i'd say probably sufficiently difficult
that um
you would need really quite a good
mathematician to do it but also not so
hard that he was
really you know laboring for years or
something like this it was the kind of
thing where originally
um
his kind of first honestly like as we
were going through this first feelings
when we were getting these conjectures
together was like oh this is super
interesting and it seems true but i just
i'm not really convinced that i
necessarily will be able to prove this
and i then over the course of like a
week or two
decided to sit down and just see if he
could prove a weaker version of it and
very quickly i think made a lot of
progress and then i think ultimately
got the bulk of the proof within
i would say a couple of months but again
you know mark would know that a lot
better than i would
thank you
uh i have a
question yeah
uh can you hear me
ah yes i can oh yeah thank you um yeah i
was
i was just wondering so in the uh i
think it was in the last page
uh there was a figure on the saliency uh
score uh the normalized silence score of
the geometric invariants and um
i was just wondering based on the
uh on this plot and the conjecture
itself so the volume of the knot shows
very show very very low uh basically uh
sensitivity to the uh prediction however
it shows up in the
formulation in the conjecture as
basically
somehow proportional to the volume
so
yeah could you elaborate on that thanks
yeah that's a that's a really good point
um
well picked so the the reason that the
volume doesn't show up
is because the um
uh
because this
model is only doing um
is only making a mean prediction
so it's not um it's not predicting a
kind of variance around the um
prediction that we're making and the
volume
only uh controls the error term
of uh
of the slope and the signature
so my expectation is if we had a model
that was actually predicting
not only
its kind of best guess of the signature
but also the variance around it you
would see that the variance
um
would
that be various aliens like the
prediction of the variance would be very
salient on the volume
but the volume gives you no extra
predictive information
uh for your best guess
of the signature
so
uh
and and it's kind of symmetric in some
way where it's yeah it's not giving you
any information whereas there kind of is
in the in the short due days in the
injectivity radius because it is telling
you something else um
yeah there's kind of there is
information about what's happening in
this actual relationship whereas the
volume is this more generic thing where
it's just as the nuts get bigger this
relationship is weaker which is a kind
of also expected thing i'm just
listening
is that okay
okay
um does that is that a kind of
reasonable answer to the question
uh yeah uh i think so i i think i got
what you say
so
i know
there's no video
uh
so my other question would be that uh is
it is it possible to also
i mean
changing the inductive bias or oh i mean
using dr bias or basically changing uh
the architecture in order to
maybe formulate or capture higher order
correlations uh between the uh geometric
and uh algebraic variants but how do how
do you see this path uh as far as i see
like this conjecture shows only uh
basically provides correlation
uh between uh the slop and the uh
basically
uh the signature
yeah so um
that's a good question i i think my
general feeling would be that
uh there's a very
the neural networks as a function
approximator or if we even just sub this
out we'll say like um
any of the modern machine learning
function approximators will do a pretty
good job of
finding any of these functions if
they're kind of sufficiently smooth and
reasonable ones
and i should emphasize that the slope uh
certainly wasn't an input into the
network originally slope was a derived
quantity that we came up with that
summarizes those top three
um inputs to the network so
in this case uh you can't
it's actually kind of interesting you
can't notice
the relationship with signature from
even any pair
reeling of those three features you
actually need all three of them in order
to make a reasonable prediction and so
that's like obviously the lower limit
of um
you know finding a higher dimensional
function
but i think it's actually quite nice
from an expository perspective to see
something simple which
is not a linear relationship and it is
multivariate in a kind of meaningful
sense here but it's still small enough
to very much get your head around
so
i think then to address the first part
of your question about
would it be interesting to
structure the network in a way to i
think you were saying kind of take into
you know add more inductive biases like
structures to the network
um to try and help it find um
functions of a different type
and i think that is actually uh a really
important and interesting question i
think this is a little more clear in the
second example
um but i think even here
if um
if you had a bit more of the
expertise of both if you have a better
understanding maybe of what you're
expecting the kind of function you're
expecting to find from the input space
or geometric invariance
and you don't think that it's going to
be captured well by a generic function
approximator and then absolutely like if
you have domain knowledge i think uh
getting that in there is always going to
be a good thing
thanks i i have one more question and
then you should probably move on to the
second example there have been books
that do similar supervised learning and
then use a symbolic regression to
find candidate functions such as in your
case the slope did you consider using
that do you think that might work here
um yeah i think again kind of looking
back after the fact
i very much think that you could find
this with symbolic regression you know i
think you've got all the tools there
especially you know any symbolic
regression package if you have say
here's three terms
and let's find um something that
minimizes this
i actually expect that uh
that we would
um we didn't in this case but uh
yeah i absolutely think you could
um great i'll uh move on i'll just check
sorry so i'm in full screen what our
timing is so we get 20 minutes okay
that's it's all good um
try and go through this and leave some
more times and questions at the end
so representation theory
as what we did with geordie
and this is a little more just a slide
of saying a lot of the work
in the collaboration is
is again just understanding both
starting to understand the field and
finding a way to work together and
understanding um
kind of what needs to be done and how
so it took us a little while going
through lectures of geordie before we
understood even enough basic
representation theory
uh to get going
but uh in some sense the problem that we
focused on
one of the reasons we focus on it is
that it's a
it's a nice little microcosm which is
reasonably understandable from objects
that we'd be familiar with
so we were looking at uh symmetric
groups
and just as a quick reminder
special groups of permutation groups
the elements of permutations
something like abcde would be the
um kind of trivial permutation of five
elements
uh and you can apply permutations
uh
to each other
in this case
but applying the permutation three two
four one five would take the uh
element in slot one move it to three
keep two the same
move three to four and so on
and so with these elements and then
the grip action we have a definition of
the group
and these are the kinds of groups
that representation theory
uh tends to study so they're one of the
type of groups called coccidor groups
and the other part that's interesting
about these groups is that you can
understand a lot about their structures
by things called reflections
and so for the permutation group
the reflections are any permutations
that just swap two elements
and so in the four element permutation
group there are six reflections which
are listed here
you can see all of them
swap two of the elements and keep the
other two elements unchanged
the other
concept that's important is simple
reflections and simple reflections are
reflections of neighboring elements in a
permutation
so with all of these
excuse me
we can define one of the fundamental
objects of study in representation
theory which is called the bruja graph
and
the graph
essentially just represents
generating the set of permutations
starting from
the
trivial element
and using the reflections as
generators
so i'll just show you an example of this
this is the kind of thing that you would
get so this is the brew hug interval for
the whole of s4 and on the bottom you
can see we start with the trivial
permutation
you start applying these generators and
i think the dotted lines here are going
to be simple reflections
uh with all the others being the
remaining reflections
and you kind of keep going up the tree
generating elements
until you eventually
arrive at the flipped permutation
and you can also then
define a bruja interval for a pair of
elements in this graph by very roughly
uh taking the sub graph between those
two nodes so you just pick out those two
nodes
kind of roughly the subgraph between
them
and that's their through higher interval
so for any two elements in this group
you can also define what's called a
cached analytic polynomial
which is
this important basis that's kind of the
basis set on which all of representation
theory is built
it's a polynomial with integer
coefficients
and
there's this central conjecture and
representation theory which says
that it's called the combinatorial and
variance conjecture
and it says that you should be able to
calculate the kl polynomial
just using the unlabeled bruja graph
and this has been around for 50 years
it's kind of long believed that this is
possible
um and there's no counter examples
obviously where
that bruja
the same unlabeled brew high graph goes
to different cow polynomials
but it's not known how to do this it's
there's a clear and simple algorithm for
calculating it when you have the labels
so if you know
which
reflections are on the edges or if you
know which permutations are on the nodes
but if you take that information away
it's not known
so the fundamental mathematical question
here is
does there exist a function that maps
from a brew higher interval to its
associated chao polynomial
and one of the reasons this is a
challenging problem is because
brew higher intervals get very big very
fast
and the kl polynomials
stay fairly trivial until you start
getting big
and so
up until
up until now i guess recently
it's known
what
determines the constant term of the
polynomial and some information about
the first coefficient
but anything for higher coefficients is
really only in very restricted cases
and to kind of
make that point stronger this is the
smallest graph
i believe that has
a non-zero coefficient for q squared or
above
um and
from here on they get very large so our
interesting graphs are all hundreds of
nodes or thousands of nodes
and
not densely connected but dense enough
that it's pretty hard to see what's
going on so if you look at this
maybe you could ensure that like see
something i can't
this is another small example from s6
and really you know if you talk to
mathematicians the interesting
structures happening
for big examples in s8 or s9 and so
those are
too big to even reasonably render
so this is another reason as i was
saying before where computationally
detecting patterns can hopefully be
helpful is these objects are really
large so we can't even look at one
effectively let alone a data set of them
and i'll kind of skip through here we
can go back um but this is to say that
we can look at
the algorithm
for the kl polynomial in the case where
you have labels
and try and use that to get some
intuition about what neural network
structure might be helpful so this is
i think close to what was being the
point that's being made in one of the
previous questions where
we're going to be encoding
um
prior knowledge
in the structure and invariance of the
network
and very approximate because we're kind
of basing this on a
known algorithm in a case which is we
obviously can't do the same thing but
maybe there's some intuition there that
carries over
and we're going to frame this as a
prediction problem where we're
predicting as taking a graph as input
and then
predicting
the coefficients of the kl polynomial
and we just do those independently
and our first initial experiments looked
pretty good in that if you look at the
baseline accuracy
to predict these coefficients it's going
to be quite low because there's a lot of
choices for the coefficients in these
data sets except
in the case of uh
this data set uh q to the four
will often be zero or one um whereas
there's a lot of action happening in q2
and q3 and also q
so this is an encouraging result
um but we wanted to try and again get
some intuition across about what's
happening here so we can make progress
on the mathematical problem
and again we fall on a similar technique
in part because you know i feel like the
field in general of its attribution
interpretability of machine learning is
less well-developed than say
supervised learning
here what we do
is we use the same gradient saliency
technique to get uh measures
of the importance of different nodes in
the graph
and then just look at uh
subgraphs induced by the particularly
salient nodes
and i've in fact put the same graph here
twice but if you look through a
reasonable data set of these
now smaller graphs
there was a
an obvious
point comes out there's these structures
at the very top and bottom which repeats
uh very frequently
and if you look in particular as to what
these are
along with observations that have been
been made previously about this problem
in the literature there's this idea that
the structure of uh dihedral intervals
or essentially these kind of diamond
shaped things
close to the bottom might be
particularly relevant for the prediction
and so to try and
validate this hypothesis we change the
input space
and rather than predicting from the
entire graph
we predict from these dihedral interval
structures
annotated with information which is not
privileged
and if we go
in that setting we see that we can
predict
uh very very accurately
on a held out set of graphs
which is
i think validation that that is the
useful information that we should be
looking at
and we were able to make the second
observation
looking um at the graphs
is if we look at the salient subgraphs
and then
see the
presence of the different
types of reflections
so on the left this is a heat map
where every element of the heat map is
one of the reflections so the bottom
left corner would be the reflection
which swaps at 0 and a
we can
this is information which isn't given to
the network
but we do have and so we can see
uh what edges are remaining in the
salient graph and we can see there's a
big difference between
the simple reflections and the
non-simple reflections which is probably
to be expected given the structure of
the problem
but additionally
uh there's a over emphasis of extremal
edges extreme reflections here which
involve either the first or last slot of
the permutation
and
this
um was something particularly surprising
that we kind of thought about for a
while
and eventually suggested to jordy
that what we should possibly be looking
for is some kind of structure which is
mediated by these extremal reflections
so something
which separates out an extremal part of
the graph
from the um
the rest which would effectively live in
a
the lower symmetric group it would be a
kind of inductive piece
that would exist in a smaller symmetric
group
and
this kind of decomposition is
illustrated on the right
and this is nice because not only does
it
reduce
a lot of the complexity here because
you're only you can split it into two
pieces you only care what uh the piece
is supported by so you the grey bits are
then in some sense uninteresting
uh it's also kind of natural and
beautiful
formula for him
for splitting these up and that there is
a closed form solution
to calculating the ko polynomial
if you're given this partition
and so this was a pretty
a big deal
for jordy because this still uses some
privileged information because you need
to know which are the extreme alleges
but this is now using very a very small
amount of privileged information uh and
there is a provable algorithm which
works in this case where you have the
hypercube decomposition
so this in itself was already
a lot of progress on a previously kind
of very hard intentional problem
uh and the bonus in this case
is looking at this uh kind of algorithm
instruction more
it turns out that you can
you can use this algorithm to calculate
the chao polynomial in all of the
examples that we've
been able to test on
so
even though you don't know the canonical
decomposition if you perform this
procedure on any decomposition which has
the correct properties that you can you
can validate uh you always get the
correct answer
so
the final
outcome we had from this work is this
conjecture
that the algorithm
that we suggest does calculate the cal
polynomial uh although we haven't proved
that yet
so i think this would be a good point to
ask for some more questions
yeah so so i have a question um
so about this conjecture coming up with
like any random hypercube decomposition
is probably
not hard
or from
that's a good question um
it's
reasonably well
not not crazy hard i mean the way that
we we verify this conjecture is we uh in
order to verify this conjecture two we
enumerate all possible decompositions
which involves all
um splitting of the base nodes into two
groups
and then
doing a bunch of validity checks to to
see whether or not it seems like it's a
valid decomposition
okay thanks
so you need to search across those
there's usually a bunch of consistent
ones but uh yeah it varies
in particular finding a hybrid
decomposition is in p and not nv
uh oh the question is is finding a high
q decomposition in p and not np um
it is in polynomial
no hold on
i can't remember basic math what's
i guess it's going to be you're going to
have to go through
um
because it's like a combinatorial
picking two two elements right so
things that aren't like finding clicks
you know so it's not enough
it feels like there's a factorial in
there somewhere um but then i'm also not
sure how many consistent um things so
yeah it's not obviously np
all right
uh okay any any other questions
yeah
maybe you can answer
sort of the analog of the question that
was asked for the other example as well
so
can you sort of indicate how much time
it took jordy to to prove like the
theorem from the previous slide
um through this room from the previous
slide
so this one this one was more
uh
mathematical work i would say
um although to be
this i think this theorem
is probably
this is this is a very difficult
statement for me to make actually but i
think this theorem isn't it was an
easier one for jordy to prove than say
the not theory
statement once
um it was
more effort
in trying to
uh
kind of turn this observation of the
hypercube decomposition into
into what that algorithm was so i guess
um
there was there was also some back and
forth experimentation where jordy was
trying to
um
based mostly on understanding of this
decomposition
uh figure out how you could put that
together and i think that took a little
bit of a while once it was there the
proof that it was correct was relatively
easy
um and then
the final conjecture is also some behind
the scenes there of like what what does
it mean to look like a
decomposition in getting that framing
right
so that took a while um and then we
spent a little bit of time trying to
prove it but that was not something we
could prove in the kind of time that we
had
okay cool
thanks
i also have a class
yeah
can you go back to the um slide with the
hypercube decomposition please
yeah
yeah so if i understood correctly um you
have empirical evidence that the reds
and diamonds
are sufficient to predict the polynomial
and you have a theorem that's the blue
and the green so the hypercube
decomposition is able to do it in any
case
so shouldn't then be like the
intersection of both of them enough
um
so
yeah thanks i left out some kind of
information there so in the in the
experiments showing that the first order
neighbors and diamond hoods are
sufficient uh what we were doing was
um
essentially
giving the networking less information
from the graph but kind of an easier
time by summarizing
uh summarizing the bit of the graph
that's being left out by its like his
interior kl polynomial
and so this sets up this recursive
um
you know the neural network is actually
in the middle of a recursive task where
you're saying assuming that we have the
chaos for these smaller intervals which
would all exist in small symmetric
groups um can you tell just from the
kl's and this diamond structure what's
going on and it can
which
leads to some non-trivial observations i
guess about the hypercube decomposition
majority of it then once you have that
you don't need the annotations anymore
for the
hypercube decomposition you you can just
look at the objects themselves and
you're kind of fine
thank you
great um i'll just give a kind of quick
wrap because it seems like we're getting
out to the end of time thanks again for
having me here but i think um
hopefully this just
there's a couple of good examples what
what i think i've
learned from this process is a little
bit more what mathematicians care about
when it comes to
their work and what they
what they enjoy using and how they can
use technical machine learning to get
results that they actually care about
and get excited about
which is what led us to these uh you
know these things that we tried
and
uh it seems like there's a lot of scope
to use other tools to kind of help this
process even faster i think already here
you guys have identified a bunch like
symbolic regression
um maybe looking at the changing the
structure of the networks in order to
find different functions
and we didn't really talk about it but
the counter example search in the not
theory work
was done very manually but
uh again after the fact it seems like
the kind of thing we could have found if
we'd uh if we tried learning to look for
it so
i think the more we worked in this
process the more it seems like there's a
good attack surface for
machine learning to help in a number of
different ways uh in this process
and um
which is not even to say anything about
the theorem proving side which i think
there's a lot of super interesting work
on separately for this so i think it's a
super exciting area and thanks for
letting me come down and talk about it
thank you
[Music]
do we have questions
i have a question
please yeah
um so you kind of mentioned like on the
on the uh
for the machine learning researchers
like kind of the next steps and stuff
but for like mathematicians who who kind
of have
these sort of objects like they they
work with you know finite structures of
or groups rings knots you know whatever
and and they have the ability to
generate this sort of data and they're
interested in doing this sort of
analysis
um do you have recommendations for
for that sort of group like best
practices advice that sort of thing
yeah um
i think
my general suggestion would be to um for
mathematicians would be to find
someone who does machine learning uh and
work together with them i think the uh
hopefully this can just be an example
that that kind of collaboration can work
effectively and this is one you know one
way in which we did so but i think
there's a lot of
a lot of scope that could come without i
think it's certainly possible for
mathematicians to just go it alone and
i think there's good results
there's one i particularly liked which
was the uh wagner's kind of
combinatorial uh construction counter
examples with rl
and um so i think that's possible but i
think there's a great
uh
potential for working together just
because a lot of machine learning people
don't have the necessary maths
background and i think for the kind of
work we were doing you really do need
good mathematicians with good intuitions
about their field of study
and there's not a lot of mathematicians
who
spend the time computationally to want
to learn these frameworks and to run
these kind of experiments so i think for
mathematicians finding a
machine learning researcher of some kind
who is interested in the area i think
would be a great start
thanks uh let me ask a few a few more
questions along uh this line so just in
terms of the
resources that were needed for uh this
project so so as in contrast with let's
let's say alphago is is it is right that
you didn't need a huge farm of gpus and
advanced computational power to do this
yeah that's right
yeah that's
that is true something i should mention
here is that um these models are
actually pretty easy to train so we um
if you if you're interested um you can
access the kind of python notebooks
that train and replicate these graphs
and the not
ones
theory
super super quick to train like you can
kind of train this in a couple of
minutes
really um to to get these first results
out
the representation theory takes a little
bit longer i think to get the proper
attribution plots out you need to train
on a gpu a single gpu for maybe like
four or five hours
so
that's um yeah it's a little bit of time
but it's certainly a lot less than than
alphago
right and and uh
again some machine learning projects one
spends a great deal of time of curating
data now now your guess some of the data
was already available like tables of
knots how much of your time did you have
to spend uh either
working with that you know preparing
that preparing new data
oh that's a good question i think in
this case
um
less than other projects but still a
decent amount of time i would say maybe
10 to
15 percent of the time would have been
spent on getting the data
right
here and in general well i think
actually even in representation theory
honestly uh quite a bit more we had to
generate a number of different data sets
and that did take some time so maybe
even 20 25 there
are you making that data available to
people or
yeah the um all that data is available
uh is kind of linked from the the co-lab
and i think it should hopefully be there
should be a link to that in the paper
too so if you want to check out that in
particular you certainly can
i have a question can i is there is
there's still space for that
yes yeah
um hi uh all right so to what so like
this kind of project seems like
sort of an artisanal project in the
sense that you know you guys found like
some
you know interesting particular problem
and you worked with a mathematician to
kind of understand
like to kind of communicate the
subtleties of the problem and you know
maybe make some conjectures this is a
really great model for how
mathematicians and machine learning
people might collaborate
uh on the other hand my understanding of
the archetypical deep mind model is to
work on like challenge problems you know
what's a central kind of question which
if you resolve sort of like
you know opens up a new domain
uh to what degree do uh
uh machine learning people have interest
in trying to like identify you know like
larger challenge mathematical questions
um besides in domains that aren't
theorem proving i mean their improving
is obviously relevant because of like
whatever auto-generating code you know
so there's a lot of sort of support for
that but in terms of
kind of more kind of pure science
questions
does that make sense yeah
yeah that definitely makes sense to
question i think that's something we
certainly think about uh too because
yeah i i think there's a lot of
enthusiasm for people for these kind of
imo grand challenge style things where
like can we can we start to get
real generalization from the ground up
in machine language i think often
excites people and gets people
enthusiastic because they're like yeah
let's kind of solve that full stop
rather than a particular problem
in this in this kind of artisanal way
but i think there is a different axis of
that we can scale along here where we
can
look and see okay if we work together
with
the mathematicians we can solve
problems that are that are this hard
using reasonably simple techniques if we
go to more
sophisticated techniques or we try
different things
can we expand the
the impact of the maths that we can we
can have
right because like if you um you know
sort of solving math is the sort of
thing that you know if you're machine
learning people person you're like okay
well probably solving math is easier
than strong ai so like maybe that's a
warm-up challenge
um but as your mathematician you know
you're like okay cool uh but there is
this sort of like intermediate ground
for like you know maybe building
transformative tools
um obviously you know you're working not
you know this sort of logic technology
work has such a grand story history in
mathematics like you know building
computational tools which really change
things i mean
you know parallel to what you guys are
doing obviously this is like very not
machinery but like you know the heyguard
fleur people have just crushed a million
problems uh and a lot of that has been
has relied on computational tools
um so like you know it's these sort of
there's these there's this potential for
kind of you know intermediate scale
problems which aren't you know like they
don't they don't sort of have like the
grandiosity of you know like the strong
ai dream but they're sort of bigger than
uh i mean there's some sort of challenge
to identify those which i think is very
interesting
um kind of
place that mathematicians and ai people
have to kind of try to talk to if
they're interested in all in it but so
i'm kind of that's what i was asking
like to what degree do you guys like
care about that because that's a
different kind of collaboration you know
yeah i think i think we care about that
a lot another way to frame the thinking
on this is
um
you know of what you what you generalize
from and and i think you can
what really excites me and i think
others as well that we worked with is if
you
if we consult like if we can show that
we can solve an actual problem that is
hard at maths can we take that use that
as an example and generalize outwards
right rather than the kind of
tabularizer generalization like okay
let's start with
you know the simplest possible formula
and generalize outwards of maths and up
yeah you want like techniques which you
could use in more complex settings uh
that makes sense okay that's a
reasonable way for like that's kind of
why you guys would want to do this
besides the fact that math is fun okay
awesome thank you yeah but also mostly
the math is fun of course
yeah i i also have a question but go
ahead mike
yeah yeah it was another question along
the lines i was asking before to what to
what extent did
you use uh
you know
generally available publicly available
software and to what extent did you use
anything particular to a deep mind you
developed for this project so
particularly the attribution technique
yeah um so the only
external software that we used was
snappy so this is a kind of library for
calculating variance knots
um in terms of the attribution
techniques
we were writing our models in um in
jacks which is
one of the
people probably know one of the machine
learning frameworks
and because we in we deliberately chose
a very simple attribution technique that
was somewhat general which is
essentially just
taking derivatives
and also something obviously the
mathematicians understand very well like
i can explain in half a sentence what
we're doing they're like oh okay that
makes sense
um
yeah we just are using jacks directly to
calculate that gradient and so there was
there's nothing needed except for the
machine learning library
okay thanks
uh johan
yeah so do i
do i understand correctly that like the
type of problems that you could apply
this approach to
you would sort of
already
need to
be able to map the problem into
discrete
structures like these graphs or or
you need to turn it into a
like an embedding into our end or like a
bunch of real numbers at some point
right
um yeah
yeah i i think you've definitely
uh
or described
neural network way of looking at things
you can
you can have whatever objects as input
as you want but you you need to perform
some process you're probably going to be
performing some process reinventing it
into rn not necessarily completely like
because i guess in the graph neural
network that we have
you could choose to visualize it in our
end but really you have a kind of iron
at every
node and edge
which are performing this kind of
message passing
so it's a bit of a question of how you
choose to think about it um
but i think
fortunately we're pretty agnostic about
what the objects look like but it it is
up to whoever's doing the modeling to
understand well how do we take this
object and
create uh
have some kind of function approximate
which is going to be able to reason
about it
yeah
okay thanks
questions uh
so andre is there
for friends that's the
previous question
[Music]
okay
well if if there were more and more
questions uh well let's let's thank uh
alex for a really very uh interesting
and right
talk
thank you very
much uh next week we'll have uh michael
bronstein from uh oxford talking about
uh graphical um
so
great you can ask him any questions you
have about the craftiness that you might
have thought right
so
thanks everybody for coming in thank you
again alex
thank you for having me